so let's move to the second point and
that's just uh the significant and
structural divides that we're
increasingly seeing inside of
democracies and of course mostly in the
world's most powerful democracy the
United States talk about why this is one
of the factors that you consider such a
big driver for a change in Global Order
well it started with the populism that
became more apparent When Donald Trump
first came in
um
populism didn't exist much in a
developed world and didn't exist in the
U.S and um and I needed to study it
populism of the left and populism of the
right and what I meant is or what I mean
by populism is
um the person of the left or the right
the leader who will fight for that group
in a fight against the other group so
history has shown that populism of the
populists of the left and populists of
the right then uh begin to gain power
under this set of circumstances when
there's a large wealth Gap and there's
the financial part so it became very
relevant to me because it changed how
the wealth pie was being shifted so for
example When Donald Trump came in tax
changes had a big impact on financial
markets and as a result you could see it
you know reverberate and you could also
see what was happening between states
start to change so I needed to study
that conflict and I S and I plotted it
both the wealth gaps the income gaps and
I plotted uh the political gaps and all
of those were the greatest since the
1930 to 45 period in fact greater than
that period going back to 1900 and we
could see it every day